hallo mein outfit bekommen wir heute zu
einem neuen video der zeit reagieren
wird natürlich youtuber auf youtube kann
habe ich mir gedacht ja das gibt es
leider auch von mir und zwar hat nicht
der youtuber als packerin ein video von
mir genommen und hat das ein wenig sag
mal bearbeitet wird sagen wir fangen
direkt mit der ersten szene des videos
ich habe mir die klage wahrscheinlich
dass laut alfa calvin habe ich also
meine tage ja ich bin froh wie schon mal
weitere jetzt geht das video wirklich
lohnt
heiße und ja wir müssen reden da die
mich an dieser stelle dann auch mal ganz
gut bei euch fortan meine damen und
herren hey ich bin derzeit auch schön
weekend werden die ich mal beschissen
eine scheiße ich mag beschissene scheiße
weil das so lieber auf mich gegenteil
verdienen oder die fitte leute die diese
weise wie ihr graben oder gegen
irgendwelche anderen irgendwie handelt
diese kommt hätte ich mit dem körper nur
aus dem wort scheiße aber vielleicht
kriegt einen tieferen sinn beginnt so
immer wenn ich hier bei mir zu hause in
meiner wohnung willen kümmere ich mich
unglaublich viel um scheiße und mit ihr
nicht die polizei in familien oder in
youtube sorgen gefasst ist also bei mir
immer so dass ich wenn ich zu hause bin
die ich überhaupt keine zeit in meiner
familie in meinem beruf in der scheiße
ja das ist tatsächlich die wahrheit zu
zeigen dass es mir neben video wirklich
nicht um teilte die ich will mich heute
viel mehr auf die community des teams
erreichte als soldat an dieser stelle
indem wir ganz klar dass die gepusht
wurde und bei der kommentare eigentlich
mehr leitet er gerade leicht ist scheiße
also freunde werde jetzt dieses video
ist scheiße klassenleiterin gescheite
seit ich weiß jetzt muss
beispiele und 4 kommentare aber wieder
davon
noch ist vieles läuft und ich sehe doch
unsere anderen videos von mir das
schreiben die leute gefährdet challenges
erstmal alle leiden wenn die scheiße
weit und alle jetzt mein kommentar
schreiben wir die viert oder ok ihr
müsst der daad in die kommentare
schreiben
und du stirbst was ist das eigentlich
für ein video aktive video entdeckt und
angezeigt wurde die youtube km von
contres runtergeladen wieder kein wir
kommen so wie gestern und vorgestern
bemüht verstehen freunde ich beschäftigt
er sich mit dem bachelor arbeit und habe
die abgabe in zweieinhalb wochen mit
spur ich bin jetzt gerade glaube ich bei
35 weise von 60 deswegen bin ich derzeit
nicht so häufig zeit für video dabei
hergehen einmal weiter rauchen 2010
verstellt an die leute die durch dummen
kommentare schreiben das dieser
irgendwelche leiden worten darum auch am
umzug ihre das war ein schöner abschluss
oder auch auf den punkt zu kommen ihr
seite warum kommt er eigentlich auf den
punkt das video dauert noch meine
familie und die amerikaner und ja wir
müssen bescheiden ich habe also
anscheinend meine tage und sie müssen
alle mal zusammen schweißen mensch
dieses video beinhaltet so tief wenige
aussagen ich weiß dass sich jeder
youtube abonnenten gelöst hat und macht
das jetzt nicht so wie einige andere
youtuber und sage ich deaktiviere die
kommentare das lässt sich deaktivieren
weil das ist eigentlich nie der fall
also freunde an der stelle ist
deaktiviert
die kommentare dann bin ich irgendwann
wieder deaktivieren kann macht wieder
gar keinen sinn aber hey was macht luca
den studenten kritisiert abonnieren mich
und meine familie
wenn man so will dazu eine
pornographische abonniere also mächtig
wie abonniere meine familie und ich
finde meine community einen scheiß
kommentar zu schreiben
freunde schreibt alle scheiße in die
kommentare
oder kacke oder du bist tot oder so dass
nicht nur noch unglaublich erfolg bringt
muss ich wirklich an der stelle sagen
wenn ich die kommentare silvia like und
du bist voll wenn ihr auch keinen bock
auf montag hat und herr eick und sommer
beim einfach bei dach sitzt das sind
erfolg bringende kommentare freunde
genauso hab ich mir dann die community
aufgebaut mir auch nicht so wirklich
verstehe kann ich sagen wollte mich
einfach abgeschrieben
die bewertungen liegen tagen an der
stelle noch mal freunde ich hoffe ihr
nicht verstanden was ich euch heute
mitteilen wollte hier findet jetzt die
moment mal die eingeblendete der druck
könnte meinen kanal kostenlos abonnieren
verpasste ich keine videos mehr da oben
sind auch menschen die unten im video
verlinkt und ich schreibe besser